curiosity stream is the world's only
streaming service dedicated to
documentaries featuring tons of amazing
titles you won't find on any other
streaming platforms get curiosity stream
for 25
off which is just 15 bucks a year by
clicking the link right underneath this
video
so one of the really common sort of uh
oxymoronic phenomena that we see in
american politics is that the people
that you sometimes see most loudly
shouting about how
the constitution says i get to do
something or the constitution says you
don't get to do something or you don't
get to force me to do something the
people
most loudly shouting that type of stuff
are often the people who least
understand the constitution we've seen
this with free speech we've we've talked
to first amendment experts about how the
people
most loudly and most frequently yelling
about free speech and the first
amendment actually don't understand it
um in the covet era in the pandemic era
that same constitutional confusion as we
might call it applies
to vaccination
very very
analogously and more and more we're
hearing that listen it's in the
constitution
you don't have to get vaccinated if you
don't want to you can't violate my
constitutional rights
by forcing me to get vaccinated we hear
that any vaccine mandate
would be a violation of your
constitutional rights and this actually
couldn't be more wrong now i want to be
really clear because sometimes when we
do a conversation like this
people wrongly think i'm saying
something that i'm not actually saying
the issue of the legality of vaccine
mandates in general by a government
is a topic of much legal discussion and
there isn't 100 agreement about could
the federal government mandate a vaccine
versus would it have to be done at the
state level or whatever the case may be
but it is not a constitutional issue
period and there's actually precedent
which we will talk to
talk about in a moment
so we can make a moral case for a
vaccination requirement but that's not
actually what this is about we could
make a cultural or a public health case
for a vaccination requirement but again
that's not actually today's topic
there is no constitutional case
against vaccine requirements so let's go
through the likely arguments that the
anti-vaxxers would make along these
grounds
they might say a vaccine mandate
violates the first amendment to the
constitution
they might say a vaccine mandate
violates the fifth amendment to the
constitution and sometimes they say a
vaccine mandate would violate the 14th
amendment to the constitution now the
first amendment protects speech the
fifth religion and the 14th the right
not to be quote deprived of life liberty
or property without due process of law i
don't believe any of these would hold up
but this is not a show where i give
legal opinions i come up with because
legal is not my area of expertise
my assessment is just
what do the legal opinions say about
exactly this issue and i've told you
before that in the early 20th century
there was a legal controversy over
maxine mandates not dissimilar to the
one we're seeing today and it took place
in massachusetts and it was surrounding
smallpox and the supreme court decided
in 1905
against a guy
who refused to get the smallpox vaccine
the the supreme court decided that the
state's vaccine requirement
slash the city of cambridge's vaccine
requirement
was perfectly fine
saying that your liberty stops
at its likelihood to damage
or do harm to other people
it's actually a relatively simple
concept even in libertarian circles sane
libertarian circles this is the case
of jacobson v massachusetts you can
google the case there's a very simple
wiki article explaining what it's all
about
so there is supreme court uh precedent
for enforcing vaccine mandates that
ruling from 1905 has been referenced
repeatedly even in the covet era even in
the covetera by the supreme court when
vaccine requirements have been upheld
this 1905 case has been referenced now
in terms of speech generally
the government can prohibit behavior
that is generally protected by the first
amendment
if it is demonstrably to save lives to
preserve life and the infamous kind of
prototypical example
is the government can ban yelling fire
in a crowded theater even though
speaking and saying the word fire
generally
is protected speech speaking is
protected speech but this is a case
where the government can actually say uh
you can't do that and people might say
but sir that's my free speech that goes
beyond free speech it goes into public
safety and the fact that yelling fire in
a crowded theater is likely much like a
ton of people refusing to get vaccinated
to have a predictable deleterious
harmful effect on public health and on
people
now there is another issue here which i
think i should mention
and it's the issue of hypocrisy there is
almost always hypocrisy from these right
wingers my body my choice on the vaccine
same with a woman's right to choose
right no no no no that should be illegal
wait a sec what
that's a double standard and we'll talk
tomorrow about what's going on with the
texas abortion law and here with the
case of the vaccines many of those
opposing the vaccine mandates
because it's government overreach
had no problem with the patriot act ndaa
mass surveillance etc
the same people who have been fighting
for decades for businesses to have all
the power
and the employees to have none
suddenly want to take away the right of
a business to say hey our business
decision is that our employees have to
be vaccinated our business decision
which conservatives have said for
decades we should have we should be able
to make decisions that are best for us
our decision is customers must be
vaccinated all of a sudden now they're
against that so yes they're pathetic
yes they are hypocrites but they're also
wrong on the facts and that's a unique
combination pathetic hypocritical and
wrong on the facts and on the
constitutionality of vaccination
mandates you do not have a
constitutional right not to get
vaccinated the details of vaccine
mandates if we see them are going to be
adjudicated and we'll we'll handle them
one by one but that blanket it's almost
used like a cudgel
uh that that's a violation of the
constitution really which which part of
the constitution or bill of rights and
the arguments very very quickly fall
apart we'll have more on this
as i assume
uh i expect maybe is a better way to say
it i expect that there will be more
legal decisions about vaccination
requirements and mandates upcoming
as we continue to follow joe biden's
approval rating decline recently
and his accomplishments
and as we continue to close in on the
start of the 2022 midterm election
it's hard to deny that the the biggest
political question in terms of the next
six to seven years of american politics
is the question of whether donald trump
will run for president in 2024
we can pretend that there are other
bigger questions because we would like
to believe that the question of trump is
over but it's not the case trump won
under unusual political circumstances in
2016 and then lost
under a relatively rare situation in
2020 where an incumbent president loses
re-election that it's not that's not a
common thing it happened eight or ten
times in american politics but
typically when presidents run for
re-election they win
trump's base seems as committed as ever
to him he's been doing rallies he says
he's going to soon be doing rallies in
key election states like iowa and over
the weekend we heard from not one but
two trump insiders his former strategist
jason miller and perpetual brown-nosing
republican congressman trump suck-up jim
jordan we heard from both of them
trump is almost certainly running in
2024 um and jim jordan even saying he's
about to announce any day so let's get
right into the clips here is jason
miller appearing on a channel or show
called cheddar news
says that the odds are 99 or 100 percent
that donald trump runs in 2024. what's
the likelihood president trump runs
again in 2024
uh i would say somewhere between 99 and
100
uh i think he's definitely running in
2024 i had a good conversation with him
last night i'm gonna go see him another
couple days here uh he has not said the
magical words uh to me but
if you talk to him for a few minutes
it's pretty clear that he's running and
i think the just what we've seen unfold
in afghanistan recently has really just
emboldened that so that's jason miller
and then congressman jim jordan says
trump is quote about ready to announce
this is video once again from lauren
windsor she's been doing great work in
this video lauren pretends to be a
republican
and uh check out what jim jordan says
and we're gonna have it from two angles
for you here
[Music]
yesterday
so jordan says trump's going to run
again i know it i just talked to him
yesterday he's about ready to announce
now they could both be wrong
they could both be knowingly lying
because there's been a decision made
that it's good strategy for someone to
claim that donald trump is is running or
likely running even when he isn't i
don't know
but more and more things are pointing
that way for sure now as i've said
before
i know that this is horrifying in terms
of what it means for the country but if
donald trump does run and is the
republican nominee in 2024
he has a really good shot at winning
based on
what's going on today things can change
but based on what's going on today
i don't know that i see joe biden
defeating trump in a rematch this is not
you know people will write to me they'll
say david you're you're poisoning the
well no i just tell you things the way i
see them right now i don't know that i
see biden defeating trump in a rematch
if biden doesn't run and it's kamala as
i've outlined before i don't know that i
see kamala defeating donald trump this
is just me being real and of course us
knowing this and getting together around
it could prevent it from happening but
my preference is to soundly defeat
trumpists in the midterms
so that trump hopefully sees
this is not looking good for me all of
my strongest followers or many have been
defeated and chooses not to run to avoid
the embarrassment of another loss if we
think of 2022 as a sort of referendum on
trumpism
and all of them lose you know matt gates
jim jordan marjorie taylor green beau
bert cawthorn they likely won't all lose
but if a bunch of them lose
that might be the signal that convinces
donald trump not to run so is jim jordan
a known liar and he might be lying here
of course sure is jason miller a known
liar absolutely it is a professional and
personal life from what we've what we've
heard
but lots of signs point to trump running
now here's the counterpoint
when i was on michael cohen's show
michael cohen of course trump's former
lawyer michael cohen said he doesn't
think trump runs in order to avoid the
shame of losing again but that's sort of
what i'm saying also if trump becomes
convinced that he will lose
i don't think trump will run i think we
just don't know that yet in the sense
that the 2022 midterms are going to be
our signal about whether trump is likely
to do well in 2024 or not either way
i believe that if donald trump runs
the gop won't stand in his way in terms
of the primary you'll have some
challenges but they won't be serious and
the party won't get behind the
challengers
but a disastrous 2022 for trumpism
may be what gets trump to say you know
what i'm not going to get involved
because the risk of humiliation is too
high
let me know what you think you can find
me on twitter at deepakman
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
the only subscription streaming service
just for documentaries my girlfriend and
i have been using the curiosity stream
platform at home non-stop i can tell you
from personal experience much better
documentary selection than netflix hulu
or amazon on curiositystream i'm always
finding documentaries by the world's
best filmmakers stuff you can't find on
other streaming services last month they
added a ton of awesome new titles to the
library i just finished watching
becoming martian
about the future of the human species
and its possible path through mars but
there's documentaries on every topic
imaginable science nature history
politics if you love documentaries the
way i do you are not going to find a
better source of brand new award-winning
docs anywhere else curiosity stream is
giving my audience 25 off which means
you can subscribe for just 15 bucks a
year not a big price tag for the hours
and hours of enjoyment i know you will
get from curiositystream just go to
curiositystream.com
pacman25
the link is underneath this video
remember that the david pakman show is
an independent media program we don't
have you know uh msnbc's phil griffin
telling me what to do or say or whatever
the case may be rupert murdoch if you
can imagine um we really are funded
directly by folks like you and you can
sign up for a membership at
joinpackman.com we do an extra show
every day
for our members and you can use the
coupon code
better21 to save off of the cost of a
membership look forward to seeing you on
the bonus show today
another brawl broke out at an
anti-vaccine protest this one is in the
uk
at the british equivalent of the
american fda we're going to look at the
video in a moment this took place at the
offices of the medicines and healthcare
products regulatory agency this is
basically the british fda
the mhra is responsible for ensuring
medicines and medical devices work
and are acceptably safe so very similar
to the us fda this video we're going to
look at this brawl
took place in canary wharf in london the
anti-vaccine protesters ended up mostly
fighting with police as they showed up
and tried to storm the building the
situation escalated when the police
started trying to push the mob away from
the building let's take a look at the
video if you're just listening you won't
get the full picture but you will
certainly be able to realize it is total
and absolute chaos based on what you're
about to hear watching it just gives you
uh even more of the insane context
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this really is like a cult of sorts and
the latest i read is that four police
officers were hurt the entire you know
back the blue defend police stuff has
gone completely out the window in these
brawls from the very same people who
normally are saying but the police the
police we must keep them safe i guess
against vaccines it's all of a sudden
acceptable
not to prioritize the safety of police
officers and of course as the protesters
become increasingly unhinged and the
police are in danger
the police start taking out the batons
and striking back at the rioters and
then the rioters use that to their
advantage they say look the police were
beating us willy-nilly
because we're concerned about vaccine
safety and of course it has nothing to
do with that whatsoever it's always the
exact same story when you see videos
like this
it's almost like these are coveted
enthusiasts like fans of the virus
protesting in favor
of the pandemic it's really crazy stuff
made even crazier when you consider some
of the facts first of all the vaccines
are safe
secondly
no one is being forced to get a vaccine
in the uk where this brawl took place
it will be mandatory for home care
workers in england they will they have
to be vaccinated as of october
english night clubs and other venues
with large crowds are going to require
proof of full vaccination starting at
the end of this month at the end of
september that's really it for now like
what are they even really protesting and
of course individual businesses could
make it mandatory schools could make it
mandatory so that's the sort of second
piece of the idiocy that's taking place
here but then third
cases and deaths
have both spiked significantly in the uk
so why wouldn't people want to go and
get vaccinated and so this is
complicated enough the pandemic
without these people
but the future of the pandemic is
particularly uncertain thanks to them
tomorrow we're going to go over a new
report from the washington post
which says for scientists the path to
kovid's end game
remains uncertain and that's a
significant understatement kids going
back to school we're very quickly seeing
cases pop up
uh some schools already closed do we
need third doses in israel they're
talking about fourth doses modified for
the variants
an insane amount of uncertainty the
people
brawling with police against vaccines
out in front of the regulatory agencies
they're not helping to bring this to a
close any faster that's for damn sure
and they're only going to extend how
long this goes on and then just to
really illustrate for you
how
significant
these delays are in getting people
vaccinated and taking safety precautions
we're going to move on to the next story
about 15 miami educators who were dead
in 10 days from covid
school in florida in most parts of
florida
started right around august 25th 23rd
etc
including in miami-dade county
15 educators are already dead in the
first 10 days now importantly
you know the the we're not saying they
all caught it at school in fact some of
them probably caught it before school
started but these are not particularly
auspicious numbers for the entire school
year here's a report from nbc
6
in miami-dade county
15 staffers of the miami-dade county
public school district have died from
covid in the past 10 days
sonia diaz a spokesperson for several
unions confirmed the number of deaths to
nbc 6.
one of the educators that lost their
life to covid was abe coleman a teacher
for more than 30 years
coleman was also a mentor and site
director for the 5 000 role models of
excellence program he helped shape the
lives of hundreds of young men over the
years in the organization that mentors
minority men
on tuesday coleman lost his life to
covid at the age of 55
55.
officials haven't released the
identities of the other teachers or
staff members and a miami-dade county
public schools spokesperson said the
district doesn't release the cause of
death
for employees or students
this is
this is a disaster on so many levels
first of all you've got ron desantis in
florida saying no masks in schools no
mass mandates in schools many schools
are just straight up going against ron
desantis and saying we're wearing masks
in schools
on a practical level
what's worse for school kids wearing a
mask
or the trauma of their teacher dying
think about that for a second i'm trying
to think back
if a teacher of mine i liked basically
all my teachers in elementary school
and the class was close to many of these
teachers
if a teacher of mine had died during the
school year it's hard to imagine
actually what that would have done i
remember when one teacher was out for a
month with heart issues and we had a
substitute and it was really stressful
for the class i remember when a
different teacher i think it was in
seventh grade fainted and emts came in
it was really stressful and here we're
talking about
15 educators some of them teachers
just dying during the first 10 days
of the school year and the alternative
of course is
not that it would have prevented every
every death some of these teachers got
it outside of school but when you see
this seriously happening
how do you say well let's just not wear
masks the masks really aren't a big deal
for these kids so tomorrow we'll get
into in more detail
what really seems to be an uncertain
future for this pandemic um and we'll
get into the details of why but not a
good start
my sister was telling me on day two
someone tested positive at her school
she's a senior in high school
and um
maybe maybe the details don't don't
really matter but the point is it's hard
to imagine this is going to go
particularly smoothly and if schools
aren't even requiring the kids wear
masks it's going to go even worse we'll
have more coverage of this on our
instagram find us at david pakman show
find me on instagram david.pacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
it's great to welcome back to the
program tom hartman who is of course
host of the thom hartmann program author
of the hidden history series the latest
installment is the hidden history of
american health care why sickness
bankrupts you and makes others insanely
rich great to have you back on tom thank
you david it's great to be here so i've
talked about this a little bit before um
wendell potter has written about this
particular thing i'm going to ask you
about uva reinhardt in his his last book
wrote about it there was a point in time
in the u.s in the early 20th century
where it was sort of looking like we may
be going in the direction of if not a
straight-out single-payer system
something much more like what germany
and some other european countries have
and that was short-circuited and there
are important political and historical
stories to to be told about that to pick
that maybe as our entry point
what happened during that time that
derailed that path for the united states
which are you talking about teddy
roosevelt 1912 uh right wait that i
should clarify because there's more than
one yeah so roosevelt in 12 and the
period between world war one and world
war ii was relevant i mean feel free to
to jump in wherever makes sense to start
the story
yeah well you know we've had multiple
american presidents suggest this and and
it has
it's not like we didn't have a role
model i mean germany got this in 1884
and it was
bismarck who was no flaming liberal
um he saw it as a way of strengthening
germany and been building industrial
policy and modifying the masses
you know for for a whole bunch of his
own reasons that were ultimately good
for the country as well
um and and we've had a number of
politicians who have tried to bring it
about
the thing that blew it up back then
which is quite different from what's
blowing it up right now or somewhat
different
was frederick hoffman and
and the prudential insurance company and
and or what was then the prudential
insurance company and
and this this whole program called
scientific racism that even president
woodrow wilson the democratic bought
into as well as pretty much everybody
else
and um
that really started in the 1790s when
hoffman came over here from germany he
was a a young man married a southern
bell down in georgia he was a an
absolute genius with numbers he was the
guy who uh working for for prudential he
worked his way up to vice president he
was the guy who figured out that there
was an association between lung cancer
and mesothelioma between smoking and and
lung cancer excuse me between asbestos
and mesothelioma
and uh he wrote a book about the
association between a processed food
diet and cancer which is still in print
so
he was a big deal at the time
and he did the math on mortality and
morbidity for white versus black people
and came to the conclusion
um influenced heavily by his wife and
the environment in in georgia where he
was living came to the conclusion that
black people were so genetically
inferior that if we simply denied them
health care for a couple of generations
it would quote solve the race problem in
america because they would all die out
he
he
the this plugged into a program that he
had helped start called scientific
racism which then led to eugenics in the
1920s
that hitler picked up in the 1930s
and that idea that if we simply deny
health care to black people for a couple
generations it will cause them all to
die out or many of them most of them um
not only animated the anti-health care
movement throughout the early 20th
century
it's the reason that southern
senators the democrats at the time the
dixiecrats
fought to have a twenty percent hole in
medicare in the nineteen sixties
because they felt that that would make
it very very difficult for black people
to get any kind of health health care
that you know they didn't want them
showing up in white hospitals or white
doctors offices
um even if they were over 65
um
and that was that was the shtick
um
i'm not sure if there's a specific other
incident that you're thinking of that
you'd like to that's a lot of the one
other is um and i think it's it's
wendell potter who wrote about this
specific element which was that um
between world war one and world war ii
there was a sort of renewed push for
going in the direction of a single-payer
system in the us but but sort of for
political posturing reasons
it felt and sounded too german at a time
when that was politically inconvenient
and that that also created a roadblock
at another time where there was some
momentum building
well frederick hoffman actually wrote a
series of pamphlets about that and gave
numerous speeches saying i'm from
germany and uh he was a rabid
anti-communist by that time
i'm from germany and this program that
bismarck started is really communism in
disguise and you don't want this
and i mean he he became the principal uh
he died in 1946 he he became the
principal spokesper person throughout
that period uh basically from 1905 to
1940 1945
against a national health care policy
his principal argument was the racial
argument he also had the
the chops the cred
to say
i'm a german i was born in germany i
lived under that system and it sucks
um and you don't want it so
you know those two things combined you
know and there were obviously a lot of
other people who were echoing what he
was saying
when you think about the situation now
that we have with healthcare in the
united states uh in terms of it as a
for-profit system in terms of a system
that that is contained within states
uh do you have a sense that the most um
radical change to use that term not
pejoratively but but the most drastic
change is likely to come from within
individual states that want to try
different things or do you believe that
the most radical change is likely to
come from the federal level down
i'm guessing it's going to happen from
the states
for two reasons one because that's how
it happened in canada and and
we're
very culturally and politically similar
to canada and saskatchewan got this in
the 1960s and then uh you know other
provinces around them said well that
really works well and it saves money huh
you know let's do that and it spread
across the country and eventually the
federal government got into the act and
said okay we will backstop you guys and
offer some standards but every every
province in canada has their own
different medicare system that does
cover all of their people but some you
know cover dental and some don't i mean
there's there's subtle differences
between
provinces
um we have in the united states both
california and vermont that have passed
legislation uh turning their states into
single-payer states the problem that we
have in the united states
is one that um i never really was able
to find out if this was
put into law
in order to prevent single-payer or if
it's just you know how the
you know clumsy aspect of how the laws
were written
but uh one of my best friends was the
the head of health education welfare in
vermont when
the when vermont
decided to go single-payer and then they
got the legislature to pass the governor
to sign and everything and he was tasked
with putting it together and what he
found was
that um
the federal law says that
medicare can go medicare payments can go
through the medicare system directly to
medicare recipients
and medicaid
uh can go through the state but it has
to go to medicaid recipients but it has
to go through a system that's basically
called medicaid or the state version of
a different states particularly for
children have their own little branded
versions but there's very clear there's
very clear definitions of how that money
has to flow
probably largely to prevent fraud or you
know states making off with it but what
it does what that means is that if
vermont was to go single-payer
vermont would have to pick up the
responsibility for all the people in the
state over 65 and for all the low-income
people and there would be no federal
funds available to them for that and so
billions of dollars every year they come
into the state would cease to come into
the state and all it takes to fix this
so that our states can do single-payer
and we like i said we've got two that
are are primed and ready to go
is a very small tweak in federal law
that blows it provides a waiver
basically to medicare and medicaid to be
able to provide that money instead of to
the recipients directly to the state
with some oversight
and
that law that change in law has been
proposed a number of times it's uh
i believe it might have passed the house
the last time around um but that's
that's the sticking point right now
sometimes uh i'll hear different
versions of uh the following argument as
to why a system that works in a country
with five million people would not work
in a country of 330 million people and
it's some version of and i'm sure you've
heard this
because the united states has so many
more people or so much more diversity in
the types of people you can't expect
something that works in norway to work
in the united states now from like a
purely actuarial perspective
in general the the bigger your risk pool
the more predictable your expenses are
going to be so mathematically i don't
really understand that that argument um
what are the reasons why that's not a
very good argument against such a system
in the united states
well let me boil that argument down for
you david it's essentially the same
argument that uh
john stennis was made you know the
southern democrats were making in the
nineteen sixties about why we need to
have a 20 hole in medicaid and basically
what it is is norway doesn't have a lot
of black people
right
that's what they mean by different types
of people that's exactly what they mean
yeah
wow and uh is there i mean this has been
looked at is it in general is it right
to say that a much bigger risk pool
overall makes for more predictable
actuarial larger country the more
efficient and effective their
single-payer system would be
and
uh
i mean you know the countries that have
done it so far and done it well you know
germany i think has what 53 million
people francis is in the neighborhood of
40 is ever i mean it's been a long time
high school geography here yeah
um
but uh
you know the uk is i don't even i don't
want to guess what the uk is um but you
know what none of these countries are
350 million people but the entire
european union is 850 million people and
uh
to the best of my knowledge every
country in the european union has some
form of a national health care system
the one exception being switzerland
which mandates everyone to buy insurance
requires the health insurance companies
to be not for profits and the hospitals
and uh and will pay your insurance for
you if you can't afford it so it's
functional the same thing but their
their system is a little more of a cluj
and as a result they are they have the
second most expensive system in the in
the uh uh developed world uh behind us
but it's still not even close to us it's
it's uh you know we're way up here in
terms of what we pay and then
switzerland and all the other countries
down here yeah on that note you know
sometimes i will tell my audience about
how
you
different countries in europe have
different systems and for example
germany's system is not
it's not what medicare what we imagine
medicare for all would be uh there's a
combination and sometimes people are
combining uh what the government offers
with some non-profit supplemental france
has a different system as well are you
i'm sort of agnostic in terms of exactly
how it's set up if we get to
universality and affordability for
everybody um
do you think that it's a
good thing to be open to looking at the
different ways in which different
european and actually singapore has a
different system as well that that's
probably worth looking at as well or do
you think that it really has to be
medicare for all as envisioned uh by a
contingent of those in the democratic
party
if you want to look at a country where
really works the best in the world and
there's no no debate about this look at
taiwan okay taiwan has a pure
single-payer system and because of that
they have a national medical database
and because of that they were on january
21st the day after we got our first
covid case a year a year ago january uh
they got their first the day after they
got their first covet case and they were
able to use that system to do contact
tracing and testing
and
kept their death rate for the entire
year of covet the first year of covet
kept it below 200 people while
you know donald trump lets 500 000
americans die
that's that's a system that works really
well
i lived in germany in the 1980s when
their health care system was still
largely 99
really just a single-payer system
what happened uh and the reason why
you're seeing all this
so-called diversity david
is that in the 80s there was this major
project launched it really was launched
in 1978 by margaret thatcher in the uk
and uh but by the 80s it had become a
whole new governing paradigm
that is sometimes referred to as
neoliberalism and its core tenant is
that government can't do anything right
as reagan said in 1980 uh january 20th
of 81 when he was inaugurated government
is not the problem government is the
cause of the problems not the solution
um and so
as country after country adopted what
are called neoliberal reforms
and as the eu began to uh incorporate
neoliberal uh
policies
into their charter the required
countries for example not exceed three
percent of uh of debt uh
in gdp debt uh a three percent of debt
relative to gdp in any given year etc
you know the stuff that just brought
greece to its knees
uh during the crash in 2009
um as that happened more and more
countries started you know that one of
the biggest pieces of neoliberalism of
course is privatizing government
functions on the assumption government
can't do anything right it's why more
than half of our power and water in the
united states is now provided by
for-profit companies and which is also
why you know california burned and 83
people died in the paradise fire which
pg e was convicted of and and why the
high tension lines down south going to
new orleans never got buried um because
they have to pay their stockholders but
anyhow that that neoliberal infection
was caught by a number of european
countries most notably france and
germany
and uh you know the the uk i think to a
large part succeeded in pushing it away
which is kind of ironic because so much
of this started with maggie thatcher but
that's what you're looking at you're
looking at ex
experiments in
bringing more and more so-called free
market stuff into health care and many
of them are just not working well at all
yes that is uh an understatement to say
the least
we've been talking about tom hartman's
latest book the hidden history of
american healthcare why sickness
bankrupts you and makes others insanely
rich
tom i really appreciate you being on of
course there's this whole other side of
the book about the medical bankruptcy
and the profitability which uh we should
we should take up at another opportunity
but i really appreciate you being on
thank you david thanks so much for
having me
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month check it
out at patreon.com davidpakmanshow all
right let's continue on a very busy news
day
over the weekend there was i believe a
rolling stone story that started
floating around about
car accident victims being turned away
at emergency rooms because they were
filled with people
who took ivermectin and that story was
not true
but because of that confusion
there is now
another story that is a real story that
relates to statements made by the kansas
department of health and the environment
that some people are not taking
seriously which is a real story
kdhe this is a press release from the
kansas department of health and the
environment okay
this is from a few days ago
kdhe urges kansans not to take
ivermectin for covet 19.
with a rise in calls to poison control
centers and visits to ers the kansas
department of health and environment is
urging kansans not to take the drug
ivermectin
unless prescribed by a physician
then take it exactly as prescribed this
drug is not approved or authorized by
the fda to treat or prevent covet
ivermectin has been approved in humans
to treat specific skin conditions like
rosacea head lice or some parasitic
worms
ivermectin is used in livestock as an
anti-parasite medicine and can be found
in livestock supply centers livestock
drugs are highly concentrated for large
animals and can be highly toxic in
humans can you believe that this is a
statement being put out
by a state health agency in the united
states in 2021
the statement goes on to say
kansans this is a quote from lee norman
dr lee norman secretary of kdhe
kansans should avoid taking medications
intended for animals and should only
take ivermectin as prescribed by their
physician these highly concentrated
doses can cause severe illness and even
death in humans the covet vaccine
remains the most effective way to
prevent prevent covet and ivermectin
overdose includes gi symptoms such as
nausea vomiting and diarrhea
overdoses are associated with
hypotension meaning very low blood
pressure and neurologic effects such as
decreased consciousness confusion
hallucinations seizures coma and death
ivermectin may intensify the effects of
other drugs that cause central nervous
system depression such as benzos and
barbiturates
covet vaccine is the safest most
effective way to prevent getting sick
and protect against severe disease i
mean it it's almost like satire it's
it's unbelievable that this is going on
they also put out a tweet
saying something very similar kansans
should not take the drug ivermectin
unless prescribed by a physician then
take it exactly as prescribed ivermectin
is not approved or authorized by the fda
to treat or prevent covid
what's really nuts to me is saying
i won't wear a mask
i won't take an fda-approved vaccine as
the pfizer vaccine now is
but i'll take something i bought from a
vet
absent any data that this is good for
covet and humans or in some cases there
are some doctors
who will prescribe you ivermectin
for covid or
i'll take something that is a is an
off-label use and off-label use can
sometimes be okay
but that has not been shown to actually
work for covid they're saying i won't
trust actual medical research on what
doesn't doesn't work but i'll trust my
so-called research on ivermectin and
they defend this practice saying you
know
the who lists ivermectin as an essential
medication it's been around a long time
it's really cheap and so they're not
making they aren't making money on it so
that's why it's not being prescribed
um but then they when asked for the data
about it being effective for kovid they
produce either nothing
or they produce the occasional
uh uh link
to the retracted study with egyptian
data where ivermectin was tested with no
placebo group so i think there's a
couple of important things to understand
number one
it is dystopianly horrible
we are in an idiocracy that the kansas
department of health has to put out such
a statement hey you know what
when you get medications meant for
animals even if it's a medication that
humans sometimes use
the animal concentration is for animals
it's not for humans that is a serious
statement put out by the kansas
department of health
uh and ultimately if people haven't
reasoned their way into a belief
it's very difficult to reason their way
out of it
unless you make them understand they
didn't reason their way in and that
means a socratic method of questioning
where you say to people
how did you determine
that this works for covet right
what evidence would change your mind
about that first you have to get them to
realize the way they got into the belief
isn't very sensible in order to expand
their uh or open them to the idea that
they could change their view and uh we
unfortunately we're going to keep
talking about ivermectin uh in this next
segment
so i'm going to show you something today
which is notable
because it's a total scam on two levels
this is sort of rare
alex jones still has a show conspiracy
theorist alex jones he has a show it's
not really appearing in many places
because he's been banned from youtube
facebook i think spotify and others
infowars conspiracy theorist alex jones
had a complete and total meltdown over
ivermectin
okay
in the segment alex jones purports
to take ivermectin
for his audience to prove to them it's
safe and it's great now there are two
scams here and i'm not going to say
either is more important to understand
than the other both are really important
to understand
the first scam is that alex jones doing
this means anything about the safety or
efficacy of ivermectin for covet
when we've actually looked at studies
there are no
actual rcts double-blind rcts randomly
controlled trials
that tell us ivormectin does anything
good prophylactically or for active
active treatment of covid uh you look at
joe rogan who took ivermectin and six
other things for something from which
most people recover anyway right i mean
doesn't mean we don't take it seriously
but most people recover and you see that
he took ivermectin and zithromycin and
monoclonal antibodies all these
different things
that's not anything that doesn't that's
nothing that doesn't tell us anything
when you look at actual studies the
study people tend to point to on
ivermectin is an egyptian study where uh
there was ivermectin versus
hydroxychloroquine no placebo group
it's it's not rigorous it's just it's
simply not rigorous so alex jones taking
ivermectin on his show doesn't actually
tell us anything second part is it
actually sorts sort of looks like alex
jones only pretends to take the pills
and actually drops it under his desk and
doesn't even take the pill so it may be
a scam on that level as well so let's
start looking at the video and see what
we can make of it i would get the kids
out of the room for this one this is
that's a disclaimer let's let's go care
people
overhead shot please you know what this
is this is ivermectin for humans you
want a nobel prize as an antiviral and
this is inhalable or these are the
tablet steroids
so let me show you okay so let's let's
stop right there
first of all
the steroid
why would you take a steroid unless you
need it steroids are not prophylactic
for viruses
steroids reduce inflammation which is
why sometimes they're given we were
looking at dexamethasone when people
have real lung compromise you give the
dexamethasone to reduce the inflammation
and maybe allow the lungs to heal
but steroids suppress the immune system
and they can actually extend how long it
takes to clear the virus so why you
would randomly take a steroid unless
you're sick and it's been prescribed
steroids have so many side effects from
a mental health standpoint they can
cause mania panic attacks insomnia it's
crazy right the whole prednisone is one
of the things rogan took and that's why
that's why it's here but i think alex
jones mostly focuses in on the
ivermectin so let's continue
i was gonna do this anyways earlier see
this watch closely see this voucher you
see this bill gates i'm gonna kill those
prions you bastard murderers and hitting
with a bio weapon you monster you want
to suppress me you want to kill me you
son of a [ __ ] you goddamn demon you
think i'm easy to kill
i think i'm gonna roll over to your crap
so listen uh i've looked at this a few
times
it does look to me like when alex jones
is making a big to-do of grabbing his
water or beer or whatever he's using to
slug this
um it looks like he sort of just drops
the pill under his desk i don't know
we'll look at it one more time and
continue i think the point is whether he
really took it or not it doesn't
actually change anything about
ivermectin i think he might have dropped
the pill below his desk you goddamn
demon you think i'm easy to kill
think i'm gonna roll over to your crap
no no and joe rogan kicked your
murdering ass too you'd love to bury him
too you little monster maggot he's in
this national geographic piece about oh
i don't usually deal with my enemies
right away i get them later yeah you
creep up on with a poison injection
dressed up in a lab coat you little
joseph mingle a nuremberg violating
monster so these are these are analogies
to nazi experimenters in terms of public
health officials right now
you damn monster
yeah i don't know that he's really
taking the pills see our little cancer
proteins like that
nobel prize winning or humans nobel
price money for humans nobel prize
winning for humans nobel prize winning
for humans so here he's actually having
a what appears to be a psychotic break
one's for humans what 2005 nobel prize
winning for humans oh joe rogan joe
rogan the
to drink the horse pace he's stupid i
bet he got it from alex jones they're
both so dumb they're both going to be
dead
yeah that's why joe's worth like 300
million dollars yeah he's real stupid
that's why he lives in a 60 million
dollar house on the river you left this
taking all the shots and dying or the
dumbasses he's the one that headlines
with dave chappelle not you you're
stupid
and i sure wish you'd wake up
but you sit there calling me stupid an
independent media person that built the
biggest independent media operation in
the world to change the whole paradigm
with my badass listeners and you sit
around and laugh at us medical doctors
gave that to me it is incredible it
helped my family it helped me it helped
everybody and it's approved for humans
for all sorts of viral stuff but that
murderer fauci doesn't want you to know
because he wants to plan it for himself
and he wants you dead well guess what
felt she when you ain't rolling over and
dying so easily you little murderer okay
so that's pretty pretty serious stuff um
now uh imagine seeing that and saying
whoa you know what it it seems like a
pretty logical thing to take ivermectin
based on what i saw and obviously no
sensible person could watch that and
come away with that belief
a complete and total meltdown from alex
jones but unfortunately for the people
that hear him talk about his supplements
and colloidal silver and you know who
knows what and they buy that stuff
it's not that different to hear him talk
about taking ivermectin and prednisone
and i mean he might have been high on
steroids that mania could be
steroid-induced mania for all we know if
he's really taking it for no reason so
the the there's two scams here i already
told you about them but then on top of
that there's the sort of social tragedy
the public tragedy
of people who get medical advice from
alex jones and it's
it's just a sad state of affairs for the
country folks really really sad state of
affairs
let's go to the voicemails you can call
me
anytime
and many do call at very strange times
during which i'm typically sleeping
at 219 to david p
i do have 600 voicemails to to triage
from the long weekend i'm working on it
but here is one
asking about whether i speak an
additional language take a listen to
this
hi david um hello sir
i was wondering whether or not your
family speaks judeo espanol or latino
this is a dying surprise language i
myself am a society jew
i was wondering whether or not your
family especially because they speak
spanish
is is a family that speaks this i'm the
first in my family in 500 years to not
speak it fluently
my family are turkish shoes
which most people don't know exist but
there is a population of jewish folks in
turkey
and we were accepted by uh sultan beijit
ii
after the inquisition
he famously told queen isabella and king
ferdinand uh what you consider to be
garbage we consider to be treasure and
accepted by family
um okay you know um my family is not
sephardic and we do not speak ladino
um or judeo-spanish i
yeah be being ashkenazi and being born
in argentina um
we just spoke spanish that's it but a
fascinating language a fascinating
language and uh i can i'm glad to give a
list of the languages i don't speak it
would just be a very very long list
um and it would make for a pretty boring
show but no fascinating history to the
language don't speak a word of it
although i don't know how similar it is
to spanish maybe it's sort of like with
portuguese or some of the spanish
dialects where it just sounds or italian
or french where it sounds similar enough
that i could understand it all right we
have a tremendous bonus show for you
today
portland is set to vote on banning
travel from texas this would be sort of
a retaliation to the new texas abortion
law
we'll talk about that on the bonus show
number two
a judge has ruled
that an ohio hospital cannot be forced
to give patients ivermectin period
and number three
el salvador
has become sort of the first bitcoin
nation they have now bought for national
as part of their national reserves i
guess is the word to use
they have bought i think it's 200
bitcoin
what does this mean what are the pros
and cons could we see more countries do
it is this crazy does it make any sense
we will discuss that on today's bonus
show how do you access the bonus show
very easy
you sign up at joinpacman.com it's that
simple you sign up and within 30 seconds
you could be listening to the bonus show
if you already have an account on
patreon or want to make one for whatever
reason you might prefer it you can also
access the bonus show by making a pledge
at patreon.com davidpakmanshow
of at least five bucks a month we will
see everybody then
or if not on tomorrow's show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
curiosity stream is the world's only
streaming service dedicated to
documentaries featuring tons of amazing
titles you won't find on any other
streaming platforms get curiosity stream
for 25 off which is just 15 bucks a year
by clicking the link right underneath
this video